I want to start off with your chances of
actually becoming a next appointment so
we can have a quick look hopefully to
show people how the last how the first
round of voting went in the Commons
these are the candidates and this is how
everyone did so you got 27 you hung got
enough to get to the next one 2033 don't
you will you do it we've had extra
support coming in so I've got a good
base and we're well-placed as build some
momentum the race hasn't really started
in earnest we haven't had the debates
yet the first one this evening we'll
have a more later in the week so I'm
looking forward to it and and we ought
to be debating the issues the vision
when I'm offering is change a change of
vision or optimistic vision I'd probably
set out more policy from degree
apprenticeships to climate change than
the other candidates but I also think we
need a generational change of leadership
I don't think the approach that got us
into this mess is going to get out get
us out of it so you're gonna get enough
and peace to get you to that 33 I'll
have you say we built on support I'm not
gonna give you my numbers but we're
building momentum are there'll be
further names in the course of this week
and I'm quietly confident the problem
you've got if you're fishing with the
same in the same pool as Boris Johnson
aren't you that's the thing and he has
got that momentum among brexit
supporting oh surely and he's certainly
the front runner he's the favorite we
know a little bit about the curse of the
favorite in Tory Party leadership
contest and I'm the underdog but I'm
gonna be the underdog fighting for the
underdog whether it's the worker that in
the lowest paid jobs that need to pay
rise whether it's the kid from the rough
background who wants their shot in life
and whether it's the British people who
fill that they've been written off in
this brexit process so I'm relishing
this campaign and we're just getting
going have you been talking to Boris
Johnson last week text messages nothing
you know we obviously bump into each
other to go to him from hustings then
I've got a huge respect for him but not
none of those sort of machination which
I think you were hinting at okay so if
you do get knocked out all of a sudden
though you don't think about this who do
you want to be Prime Minister at these
candidates I'm not getting into that no
no I'm good to run my campaign with the
optimism and the vision and will and
hopefully what we'll see this week is
the competing visions and the styles of
leadership that the different candidates
are showing we haven't really had the
chance onstage to see all of them
together and that's what I think people
be focused on this race has only just
started
appreciate it as a front-runner here but
I'm looking forward to this race now I
want to talk to you about brexit sure
it's perhaps the thing that you've said
that it's caused the most controversy is
that refusing to rule out the idea of
pierogi or suspending Parliament if in
order to push through No Deal breaks
that if Parliament tries to block it now
amber rod described that is outrageous
to me on the show today Hillary Byrnes
said it would be scandalous
yes it would be anti-democratic wouldn't
it oh I don't think it's something we
would want to do and I think it's very
unlikely but what's the real scandal you
can't rule it out well no and I'll tell
you why that what's really scandalous
about this is the way people have been
trying to sabotage the will of the
people and break their promises left
right and center to get us out of the EU
and but the reason I don't rule things
out is I've got experience in
negotiating six years in the Foreign
Office as an international negotiator
my time is brexit secretary the big
mistake we made in these negotiations
were taking no deal off the table and
when we start ruling things out we only
weaken our chances of getting a deal
I've set out my plan for a deal the
other candidates haven't set out a
credible plan but it has not I mean you
wouldn't Boris I'm not quite clear what
Boris is plan is but in fairness I'll
let him set that in more detail what I'm
saying is the others have wavered or
hated on the question of whether we'd
leave with no deal whether they're
flirting with another extension all of
that just reduces our chances of getting
the deal that we want are you really
saying that you would go to the Queen
and ask her to
Parag pond dragging her into politics in
a way that she's avoided first I won't
be dragging anyone anywhere but what I
what I think the the signal that we send
to the EU is crucially important and we
frankly made too many mistakes stumbling
in these negotiations by ruling things
out what I want the EU to know know what
I want the people of this country to
know is first of all we'll keep our
promises and secondly the EU to know
that we're serious about leaving the EU
all those candidates that are going weak
at the knees and saying well I'm not
sure about this and that they're sending
a message to the EU that frankly they
can take us for a ride we've had three
years of that it's time to get this done
I thought brexit was all about the
sovereignty of parliament and you were
saying you just overall punk it's
interesting point normally when the
government is in a clash with parliament
it is Parliament sticking up for the
people but this time Parliament gave the
decision to the British people and now
because we don't know you don't know
people voted for No Deal breakfast
do they it's not necessarily an idea we
give the people week would search in
this we gave the people a decision now
Parliament is trying to steal it back
away from them and I think that's a
fraud in terms of what the referendum
campaign decides it was very clear we're
leaving the EU now we made the case that
actually we want to leave with a deal
but plenty of questions were asked about
what if you couldn't get that deal and
what the outcome would be so when people
voted they voted to leave we haven't
left yet and that's why we're seeing not
just the uncertainty for the economy and
the damage it's doing to businesses many
of whom come to me and say we just want
to know what you're doing
but also this corrosion of public trust
and it is the Tory party will be toast
unless we're out by the end of October
the Tory part will be taste yeah I think
we're in it but people need to wake up
to this we've seen from the Peterborough
BART by-election we've seen from the
European elections not just the the
frustration the outrage you refer to
scandal the scandal that people feel
that we haven't kept up from song breaks
it could be the end of the Conservative
Party is that what you're saying I
certainly think the Conservatives cannot
win an election unless we deliver brexit
okay
now I want to ask you if probably will
come as no surprise about your comments
earlier in the campaign saying you're
probably not a feminist so what does
feminism mean to you well I'm not sure I
think the label is very ambiguous some
people argue for gender quotas or
positive discrimination I'm not keen on
that what matters more than if you say
you're probably not a feminist you must
have an idea of what it means and what
do you think well I know I'm not sure I
think it means different people things
to different people I certainly would
consider myself a champion of equality
and if you look in this race I'm the
only candidate there is not a single
candidate that has set out policies to
take forward the issue of equality of
opportunity I'm the guy arguing for
third trimester scans for pregnant mums
so that we cut down on breech births I'm
the one saying that pregnant agency
workers necessarily say that people are
gonna use
I've been I've been the one talking
about a pregnant agency workers having a
day one right to go to antenatal
appointments amazing in 2019 we don't
have that and I'm the one that's fact
Maria Miller's proposal to have
six-month protection for new mums
returning to work why because we've seen
a doubling of the number of new moms
being laid off so people talk about the
labels I'm talking about what would
actually materially advance the cause of
equality and I think issues that a lot
of women really care about so you're
talking about there is Marie millet talk
about discrimination for moms do you
think women facing discrimination than
men I think that those are real so if
you look at the gender pay gap we've
made real progress but there's clearly
an issue for women in their 40s and one
of the things we've seen over the last
ten years and I looked at the evidence
that the Select Committee had is a
doubling of new moms or pregnant moms
being laid off or made redundant do you
think women face more discrimination I
think that's a good example of where
they do certainly so if you think that
women face more just because it's not as
simple as that you think that Sophie I
mean maybe you agree with gender quotas
and positive discrimination I know lots
of women you find that insulting and
patronizing what I want to do is get to
a stage where we don't really think
about gender we just look at people
based on their character their talents
their ability and that's why I'm full
throated champion of equality and
meritocracy but the labels I think are
less important what you actually do in
life let's talk about what you do like
them because for a lot of people you
know feminism is about the fact that you
know women are often working pay less
than men they go back home and they do
the majority of the housework sixty
percent more than men do you do more
housework than you want we are pretty
good team Oh fifty-fifty I'm not sure
whether it's exactly 50/50 we don't
again we don't have a box stick approach
but I get my boys up in the morning
irena we give you up to all the sort of
usual chores but don't take a curtain
call about these yeah boys girls and
girls job boys jobs and girls jobs in
your house no and that's my sister and
that's my point sake I'm not sure that
they you know cooking your wife takes
out the window no I do a bit of cooking
she's better cook but I certainly take
out bins but I think it's a good example
where the labels faintly I don't really
help you very much remember of course
the yuca of the servation polling
suggests that the overwhelming majority
of women let alone men and women don't
really think that do not consider
themselves feminists so probably
slightly more in tune with the rest of
the country
and ambhiraj said earlier that it
bothers her that there are no women left
in the contest does it bother you
we had to him down at the last to last
time around I think what matters above
all is the quality of the candidates and
what they're offering and I think that
probably matters most but we've got a
huge talent coming through the
Conservative Party all ranks
parliamentary and Minister and I and I'm
sure that we'll go from strength to
strength and I certainly would like it
to I'm mentoring someone right now who's
a candidate through women to win I think
it's really important does that bother
you
if the women this the the gender
representation is less of an issue does
it bother you that you know five of the
six remaining candidates of white men
who went to Oxford well four out of six
went to paid for their education sure
this sort of class warfare is a
particularly attractive way to go but
look my backgrounds different from some
of the others my dad was a refugee my
mum and my dad died when I was quite
young so my mum raised us as a single
mum in our teenage years I'm a grammar
school boy but actually what really
matters is what we stand for I do think
though there is a risk when you go into
marginal seats that the Tory party gets
caricatured is the party that privileged
the party of the elite only interested
in looking after the well-off that's why
my tax plan is looking after those are
on in work but in the lowest paid jobs
so that's why I've said I'd raised the
national insurance threshold saving the
lowest paid workers four hundred and
sixty pounds a year that's whose side
we've got to be on life income well
placed both in terms my politic policies
but also my background to make that
argument you say your well place and in
terms of your policies and your
background and how about your record as
a minister because you of course the
brexit secretary that effectively was
brexit secretary when the backstop
happened you were Minister when deaths
and assaults in prisons went up you were
Housing Minister when the rate of
building new homes went down so Sophie
you're wrong all three of those points
first of all interesting I argued
against the backstop and resigned over
it secondly I wasn't prisons minister I
was courts minister and I brought
forward the courts reform agenda I also
as Minister for justice made it clear to
the Council of Europe we wouldn't give
prisons to vote despite all of the temps
to say we'd be kicked out the Council of
Europe and what was the last one you
mentioned Housing Minister from January
2018 to July when you build dwellings
were 5% down on the previous quarter
direction 20 actually when I was Housing
Minister
in fairness it was a lot of a lot of us
have been involved in this but we've had
new dwellings at the highest rate of all
but one of the last 30 years and I put
forward both the planning reforms the
new national planning policy framework
and I also did the the lion's share of
the work on the social housing green
paper so I'm proud of my record even
they take their housing that's new built
Welling that starts in in England in
2018 we're down we tend to judge it by
is the number of new homes not just new
builds and they were at two hundred and
seventeen thousand they've just gone up
over two hundred and twenty thousand
that is the highest nor but one of the
last 30 years but we've got more to do
that's why I'm arguing for cutting stamp
duty for all homes under five hundred
thousand pounds that's why I've said
that I would give Housing Association
tenants the right to buy we've got to do
much better but I am the candidate who's
not just got the experience as you
rightly say but the vision and a set out
put some beef on the bones explain how
we'll actually get there provide the
homes that young people need now you had
a bit of a take on the internet today
haven't you with the Sunday Times saying
that you're not pitching for a cabinet
job with Boris Johnson wasn't that if
they quite rightly corrected the story
because it was inaccurate and I'm
grateful for them for doing that very
good and smoothing over relationships I
like to say that now I think what sort
of Prime Minister do you think Boris
Johnson would be I'm not going to talk
about him he's a front one I come on
yeah sure but he can make his own case
means you come on your show in them well
that's something that we can agree on
yeah and discuss his plans but I don't
really think I think we need a bit more
positivity in politics so I'm going to
set out at my visioned approach that I
would take and I let the other
candidates do the same for themselves
did you serve in his cabinet Oliver said
that I wouldn't do the petulant thing of
saying I won't serve under X or Y and if
Boris has got huge talents he's look
great charismatic character fizzing with
optimism and I just think that when it
comes to not just vision but getting
things done I would be in a better place
and I also think based on some of the
issues we've talked about before and
better place to win over in those
marginal seats with my tax plan for the
lowest-paid my idea of the aspirational
underdog and giving them the chances in
life